la mayoría de las moléculas orgánicas no
tienen color un ejemplo de eso es el
eterno también conocido como etileno lt
no tiene dos carbonos y cada uno tiene
una hibridación esp dos tienen un
orbital p entonces tenemos dos orbitales
atómicos en total y esos dos orbitales
atómicos se van a combinar para formar
dos orbitales moleculares un orbital
enlazan t y uno anti enlazan t el
orbital molecular enlazan t tiene menor
energía así que este es el orbital
molecular en la santé mientras que el
orbital molecular anti enlazan t tiene
más energía
este es el orbital molecular anti
enlazan t entonces l t no tiene 12
electrones pi voy a resaltar los y estos
dos electrones pi están en el orbital
molecular enlazan t
así que este orbital está ocupado
a este orbital también le podemos llamar
orbital molecular ocupado de más alta
energía como por sus siglas en inglés y
este orbital es el orbital molecular
desocupado de más baja energía el humo
también por sus siglas en inglés y
observen que hay una diferencia de
energía muy importante entre el orbital
homo y el uml esa diferencia
corresponde a una longitud de onda
recordemos que la energía es igual a la
constante de planck por la velocidad de
la luz entre la longitud de onda
entonces la energía y la longitud de
onda son inversamente proporcionales así
que una cierta cantidad de energía
corresponde a una cierta longitud de
onda y por eso esta diferencia de
energía entre como el humo corresponde a
una cierta longitud de onda que en este
caso resulta ser de aproximadamente 171
nanómetros
así que cuando lt no absorbe luz con una
longitud de onda de 171 metros esa es la
energía suficiente para que estos
electrones bi brincan del orbital como
al humo en una transición de pi pi
asterisco hablamos sobre estas
transiciones en el vídeo sobre
espectroscopia v visible asegúrense de
ver ese vídeo antes de ver este entonces
lt no absorbe una longitud de onda de
171 nanómetros ahora vamos con el 13
butadieno miren tiene 4 carbonos y cada
uno de esos carbonos tiene una
hibridación sp2 cada uno tiene un
orbital p así que tenemos 4 orbitales
atómicos que se combinan para formar
cuatro orbitales moleculares 12 enlazan
test y 2 santi en las antes los dos
orbitales en las antes tienen menos
energía que los dos orbitales sant y en
las antes
pero vamos a ver tenemos un total de 4
electrones vi entonces cómo estos
electrones que ocupan los dos orbitales
moleculares en las antes nuestro trabajo
es identificar el orbital molecular
ocupado de más alta energía que sería
este y luego el orbital desocupado de
menor energía que sería este porque
recuerde lo que nos interesa es la
diferencia de energía entre el orbital
homo y el sumo en este caso la
diferencia de energía es más pequeña que
la anterior
entonces si pensamos en la ecuación que
relaciona a la energía y a la longitud
de onda podemos decir que si disminuimos
la energía como son inversamente
proporcionales aumenta la longitud de
onda así que debemos tener una longitud
de onda mayor a la anterior es decir en
lugar de 171 nanómetros el 13 butadieno
absorbe una longitud
de onda de aproximadamente 217
nanómetros ok
finalmente veamos el 135 exa triano
aquí tenemos 2 4 y 6 electrones pi y
miren esos 6 electrones pi llenan los
tres orbitales en las antes entonces
primero hay que identificar cuál es el
orbital molecular ocupado de más alta
energía y el orbital molecular
desocupado de más baja energía para
analizar la diferencia de energía bueno
aquí la diferencia es más pequeña así
que nuevamente si disminuye la energía
aumenta la longitud de onda así que en
este caso debe ser mayor a esta aquí es
de aproximadamente 258 nanómetros
pero esa longitud se encuentra en la
región v del espectro electromagnético
así que el hexa trieno no tiene color
pues para que algo tenga color tiene
que absorber alguna longitud de onda de
la región visible pero eso sólo se logra
cuando existe una conjugación por
ejemplo en este caso el hexa triano que
está conjugado es decir tiene doble
enlace enlace simple doble simple y
doble pero como ya dijimos absorbe luz v
pero imaginemos una molécula que tenga
más conjugación que el hexa trieno
aumentar la conjugación significa que
aumenta la longitud de onda absorbida y
miren la tendencia conforme aumentamos
las conjugaciones aumenta la longitud de
onda
entonces si tuviéramos una molécula muy
conjugada la molécula podrá absorber luz
en una longitud de onda mucho más alta y
si pasamos de los 400 nanómetros
estaremos en la región de luz visible
esa es la idea al aumentar la
conjugación habrá presencia de color
veamos el betacaroteno en el vídeo
anterior hablamos de que él
caroteno este color anaranjado así que
tenemos una molécula anaranjada y miren
la clave es la conjugación observen
todos los enlaces dobles y simples que
estan alternados si una molécula tiene
mucha conjugación eso significa que
puede absorber luz a longitudes de onda
altas que corresponden a la región
visible del espectro electromagnético en
este caso el betacaroteno absorbe la luz
azul y refleja la anaranjada
por eso las zanahorias y esta molécula
son de color anaranjado veamos otro
ejemplo fenol ftc alain la fenol talina
es el indicador ha sido base más famoso
estoy segura de que si han estado en
algún laboratorio de química general han
usado fenol talina sobre todo como
indicador en las titulaciones como saben
a bajos valores de ph es decir en un
ambiente ácido la fenol talina es
transparente pero
si agregamos una base aquí agregamos una
base aumenta el ph y observamos un color
rosa o magenta voy a tratar de explicar
primero agreguemos un poco de hidróxido
de sodio aquí tenemos el año en
hidróxido y por acá dibujaré otro año en
hidróxido el a nyon hidróxido funcionará
como una base así que toma este protón
por lo que estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá empujando estos electrones
hacia acá después estos electrones se
mueven hacia acá y estos electrones se
mueven al oxígeno ahora el otro
hidróxido tomará este protón y estos
electrones se quedarán en el oxígeno
vamos a resaltar los electrones estos
electrones en rosa se movieron aquí
ahora usaré
estos electrones en azul se movieron
aquí después usaré verde estos
electrones en verde se movieron aquí y
finalmente estos electrones en rojo se
movieron a este oxígeno así que ese
oxígeno termina con una carga formal
negativa y si este año en hidróxido toma
este protón estos electrones terminan en
este oxígeno lo que le da una carga
formal negativa así formamos un guión
esté ión es de color rosa o magenta pero
vamos a explicar por qué observen toda
la conjugación que tiene los enlaces
simples se alternan con los dobles
enlaces doble enlace enlace simple doble
simple doble simple doble simple doble y
así consecutivamente prácticamente todo
el guión está conjugado y toda esta
conjugación permite que él
absorba la luz de la región visible por
eso vemos un color rosado pero podemos
ir en la otra dirección
es decir si agregamos un poco de ácido
ácido provocamos que la fenol talina
cambie a su forma transparente y la
razón de que sea transparente es porque
este carbono tiene una hibridación sp3
por lo tanto no tiene un orbital p y
aunque tenemos un poco de conjugación en
los anillos de benceno esa conjugación
es interrumpida en el carbono central y
al no tener conjugación en toda la
molécula esta molécula no puede absorber
longitudes de onda tan altas por eso es
transparente pero miren si analizamos
este carbono este carbono tiene una
hibridación sp2 si tiene un orbital p y
eso permite que haya una deslocalización
de los electrones
y así continúa la conjugación por eso
tiene color espero que esto les ayude a
entender lo importante que es la
conjugación para el color